welcome back to cbs this morning
news of a successful coronavirus vaccine
is giving a huge boost
to the effort to stop covid the drug
giant pfizer said yesterday
that its vaccine candidate has was more
than 90 percent effective
in early testing dr anthony fauci the
government's top
infectious disease expert called the
news extraordinary
he also says there are likely to be
other effective vaccines
coming soon dr john lepuk shows what
this could mean for the fight
against the coronavirus
the news from pfizer was even better
than expected i would have been very
satisfied with a 70 percent effective
vaccine according to a pfizer press
release
out of almost 44 000 trial participants
94 got sick from kovid
four weeks after the start of the two
dose regimen and seven days after the
second dose
protection from symptomatic covid was
greater than 90 percent
we were jumping out of the chest
screaming basically this is unbelievable
oh my god
we may put an end to this terrible
pandemic
pfizer's chief scientific officer dr
michael dolston expects the company to
file for an emergency use authorization
of the vaccine
within two weeks pfizer is one of four
vaccines in late stage trials in the u.s
moderner is also reportedly expecting to
release interim data
later this month dr anthony fauci says
pfizer's results could help convince
even hesitant americans to roll up their
sleeves
you tell them by the way i have a
vaccine that's more than 90 percent
effective
there will be much more enthusiasm about
getting that vaccine
no doubt about that louisiana physician
dr victoria smith joined pfizer's phase
3 vaccine trial this summer
she sees hope in their results i was
ecstatic also you know i feel
really privileged and honored to be part
of
of history operation warp speed the
federal government's effort to
accelerate development and distribution
of a coveted vaccine
has pledged to buy a hundred million
doses enough to vaccinate 50 million
people
with an option for another 500 million
doses
we want to have multiple successful
candidates to have vaccine available
for all 7.5 billion people on the planet
dr mark mulligan leads pfizer's phase 3
trial at
nyu langone health in new york city it's
not like flipping a switch
it'll take a long time before there's
enough supply available
to get enough people vaccinated we do
need to manage that expectation
beyond supply issues there are
challenges around the distribution and
administration of the vaccine that
requires
ultra cold storage now in terms of who's
going to get it first it's going to
probably be
first responders and people at high risk
and then over the course of 2021
others will gradually get it john
john how long does the protection from
this vaccine last
big question nobody's really sure and
pfizer says it is possible that we will
need to give people boosters
so it was developed in record time what
eight months were talking about john
they're going to be some people who say
that seems awful quick i'm nervous
um what would you say to them
know aside from the reassurances from
pfizer and the fda and tony fauci
i think people would be reassured by
knowing this wasn't just whipped up out
of thin air at the beginning of this
year
it's built on decades of research there
were things called vaccine
platforms and very over simplistically
think of a prefab house
and on the top of it is the genetic code
that gives instructions for a certain
vaccine
you have a vaccine say for west nile you
unscrew that top
you put on the vaccine instructions for
zika
and then you unscrew that and put on the
instructions for sars cov2
so tony fauci was telling me that the
vaccine for the first star
stars won took about 20 months gradually
got less and less for zika it was three
months
and for this vaccine it's about two
months so that gives you more of a sense
of the arc of the technology it wasn't
just whipped up
there's real science behind this john
very quickly there's also good news on
therapeutics to help those already
infected what's that
well we have lily getting uh the first
eua emergency use authorization for a
monoclonal antibody
you remember that it was a monoclonal
antibody cocktail by regeneron
that was used to uh to treat president
trump so
there's hope that in that first week
that viral phase when the virus is
multiplying
if you can get something like monoclonal
antibodies to dampen down the virus
that it could be very helpful all right
a lot of encouraging news there john
lapook dr donald
thanks